- The last time you were here,
you told me,
you were talking about your hamster.
So has your hamster
had babies or anything?
- Yes, ma'am.
My foster hamster, Natasha,
who I was taking care
of for a friend of mine
who's a breeder in Virginia
recently had a litter of baby hammies.
Oh, that's my hamster shirt.
- Hamster Dad.
- [Kid] A lady at work gave them
Oh my goodness, there they are.
- Oh my gosh!
- Aren't they so cute?
- [Kid] They're adorable.
- That's Isla when she
- Oh my God, the cheeks.
- That's my hammy.
And she is the cutest,
sassiest little baby.
If she, if you feed her
and she doesn't want it,
she will slap your finger.
She will.
- She's sassy.
- She reaches out
her a little paw and not even kidding,
she just goes
and she throws food,
but she's adorable and really sweet.
Even though she's
- Oh my gosh, I love you.
- fairly spoiled.
- [Kelly] I love the cheeks.
That was amazing.